we always want our games to play
differently from each other and if I
were to describe how MK1 plays compared
to the previous games I say we loosened
up restrictions we really loosened
things up and so we're just going to the
player here here's a here's a a a a
Sandbox full of of toys with Combos and
adding air combos adding Cameo
characters and seeing what can you do
with it
[Music]
we didn't want to like start a whole new
thing and have brand new characters
where everybody wants to see Sub-Zero
scorpion Raiden Liu Kang you know
returns so we felt like like telling a
new story with existing characters was
like the the strongest way to go but
they're going to be reintroduced with
brand new identities backstories roles
relationships with each other and that
is basically the premise it's a brand
new story using characters that you
already know and love but in completely
different scenarios so they're going to
be reintroduced and all that at the end
of mk11 as you know Liu Kang was kind of
made the fire God and he eventually
became the keeper of all things you know
the ultimate being and so he created a
brand new universe you know created a
new Big Bang basically was trying to
restart everything with the hopes that
everything was going to turn out better
than the previous timeline of Mortal
Kombat Liu Kang's biggest difference is
he has a much wider range of projectiles
fire projectiles you know like a
standard one if you look it's like a a
very tight like yin yang that's spinning
that's on fire he has his a ground one
that's like a snake right he has uh this
gigantic one that he follows up with
with a flying kick and then he has a an
aerial one that shoots like you know six
or seven Fireballs if you catch somebody
you're gonna you're gonna be juggling
them with a number of hits so his is a
lot Wilder he's still very accessible
but it's his projectiles taken to an 11.
Sub-Zero has some recognizable stuff but
then he also has a few tricks up his
sleeves right like like he has his clone
but now there's a version of this clone
where he can do three of them really
creating like a wall of ice at the
opponents is going to have to kind of
figure their way through he has his
Classics like his his slide his
projectile and and all that but um the
big kind of crazy clone thing is is the
one that kind of stands out the most
from my perspective kenshi his big
emphasis with this game is the spirit
that he can control it's imagine like
it's this ghost that also has a sword
and the ghost can come flying from the
ceiling out of kenshi the ghost can jump
out and kind of like stand around and
fight and the player can control the
ghost independently right and have him
you know go do the dirty work and all
that so it's I I think kenshi is one of
the more sophisticated characters in the
game you know he's going to need some
practice getting in there but in
addition to that ghost he's going to
have a cameo character so in a sense the
player is going to be kind of thinking
about three characters that they're
uh responsible for katana's changed her
the function of her fans is pretty uh
pretty dramatically different
um normally they behave as projectiles
you know they hit you they do damage now
they kind of like circle around you lift
you up set you up for combos they have a
lot Wilder paths that they take as
opposed to kind of just straightforward
or something you know there's all these
curves and and they're they're more
versatile I think than than they were
before but like her fans have a very
different property that she has
foreign
[Music]
I think whenever you add a new you know
mechanic into a funny thing there's
there's challenges that come with it how
does it play with the existing things
that we had you know we wanted some of
them some some amount of familiarity but
also a Simplicity to it uh cameos
started as a completely different uh
feature our design team wanted to have
individual things like like a drone for
Sonia or like kind of like we had the
cat with atrocitus in a in Injustice too
uh basically something that would come
out and kind of help you and I was
pushing for
everything needs to be used by everyone
right we didn't want to just have the
Drone for Sonia we wanted to have the
Drone for everybody right and I also
wanted to have more of a
like like a novelty with our old old
games and and so that kind of turned
into characters that would come out and
help you and then and the fact that we
we can kind of we have Mortal Kombat has
about a hundred characters that you know
that we can dig uh dig from and and
include in the game so that really once
we started going okay it's two rosters
it's the main roster and then the Cameo
uh roster that really took a life on of
its own and so when we started
characters coming jumping out and
helping that was great we didn't want to
go full tag because it was a great
feature in MK9 but it wasn't the most
used feature right and and I think at
the end of the day it was because
players would have to learn two full
characters very completely so we just
use this utility so now you like Kung
lao's teleport grab his Cameo and he'll
grab you and teleport with you you know
you like Jax's ground pound you like
kano's ball you like all those
um iconic moves right you can take along
with you
if you like playing scorpion if you like
playing Sub-Zero right and so there's
there's uh those mixing and matching I
think is there's there's something
really special going on with that I feel
like Mortal Kombat has always kind of
taken the approach of less challenging
input requirements to to make a move
come out you know that that goes all the
way back to the first Mortal Kombat
where Liu Kang was a lot of you know tap
tap High punch tap tap low punch you
know a lot more people can do that than
a dragon punch you know it's our two
circles for Zen gives uh you know and um
so so we've always kind of
rested in that in that space of easier
control so I don't think we needed to go
too much uh easier with our controls
um and uh and certainly our new feature
The Cameo system you know it's a button
basically that you pushed you know maybe
you go towards in a way stuff like that
so it's anybody can bring a cameo
character out without being challenged
uh you know technically in terms of
input
[Music]
yeah
we're always talking about guest
characters you know the the process of
getting a guest character isn't just us
going oh it would be cool to have
Freddie in it and then he's in the game
there's owners of the IP and there's
there's all these other uh you know
requirements kind of that we got to kind
of check uh check boxes through so we're
always in a state of exploring numerous
uh uh uh you know guest characters some
some make their way through some get you
know hit a hiccup or a snag or some some
legal thing that that you know doesn't
that prevents us from doing it so we
always have
eight or nine plates spinning that we're
you know hoping to who comes who who
calls uh kind of makes it through all
the way
[Music]
foreign